hi everyone its charlie happy comic-con
a week we have to talk about some of the
really big easter eggs in the spider-man
far from home and credit scenes so
there's a really innocuous moment that
doesn't seem like a really big deal as
part of the bigger and credit scene that
winds up being this huge easter egg for
the Fantastic Four Kevin Feige even had
to come out recently and say something
about it so it's happening during that
web slinging scene when he's on his way
to meet MJ that I attached the clip up
at the beginning of this video so we'll
explain the scene and what it means for
the future of Marvel especially given
what Kevin Feige came out and said after
everyone started talking about the
Easter Egg because it's Comic Con week
there's a new round of that IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a spider-man
comment on the video I named a new
winner at the end of this and it should
go without saying but spoiler warning
for spider-man far from home if you have
not seen the movie yet because we'll be
talking about what happens during the
post-credits scenes so I've already done
a couple videos about the end credits
scenes there's a mid-credits scene in a
post-credits scene for the purposes of
this video we're talking about something
that happens during the mid-credits
scene before you get to the Jay jonah
Jameson scene where he appears in the
MCU for the first time so at the end of
the movie Peter Parker confronts happy
and Aunt May after they got back to New
York City about their relationship they
have this funny joke about them implying
that maybe we're just going to see where
things go
maybe they'll stay together maybe not
just a joke about what the plot of
spider-man 3 might be for these two
characters
spider-man's totally grossed out he
takes off because he has a date with MJ
in the new Steve Ditko suit Tom Hollands
said that they referred to it as the
Bosko suit on set but I still think of
it as the Steve Ditko suit because
that's the look that they're going for
the classic original Steve Ditko
spider-man suit he swings through New
York City giving us what we haven't seen
in a long time in a spider-man movie
showing just how much better they've
gotten at displaying the physics of
spider-man I feel like they really
nailed that during this film in all of
his web slinging scenes much more poetic
version of spider-man that we've seen in
previous versions they had started to
get there it's just a special effects
have started to finally catch up with
what your imagination can come up with
based on the comics but we haven't
really seen a big web slinging scene
like this through New York City that
looks amazing since Andrew Garfield's
amazing spider-man there's a moment
during the scene when he's
across the rooftops there's a Green
Goblin Easter Egg I'll do a separate
video about if you thought you spotted a
Green Goblin Easter Egg during this
moment here then you are correct but
that's a whole different thing we need
to talk about in a separate video
little things might seem like no big
deal but it takes a lot of people
working on visual effects to make
spider-man swing through the city like
this they manipulate the images so much
anything you spot is no coincidence
while he's swinging his way to MJ he
stops and glides through a new opening
in the newly redesigned Avengers tower
with the mystery buyer that we still
don't know about yet more about that in
a second but when he swings down through
he hangs on a pulse whirls around and
then lands on the ground if you look in
the background of this shot you can see
a very large Construction sign in front
of that Avengers Tower that says we're
so excited to show you what comes next
and it's really only on screen for a
couple seconds so almost blinking you
miss it
but there's a one-two-three in a
question mark where the force should be
so this is an easter egg for a bunch of
different things the colors of the
numbers correspond to the colors of the
Fantastic Four characters in their
powers the fact that the four is a
question mark is a reference to Marvel
phase four coming next like you don't
know what it's going to be because we
haven't told you yet but we're really
excited to tell you but it also
represents the Invisible Woman from the
Fantastic Four because it's a question
mark like where did the number four go
you can't see it because the number four
is invisible like the Invisible Woman
the street corner that Peter and MJ are
standing on is also very important for
this - because east 41st in-library way
is just a block away from where the
Fantastic Four's Baxter building is in
the comics
so I know a lot of you are wondering now
if the Fantastic Four are the mystery
people who bought the Avengers Tower
from iron man in spider-man homecoming
in Kevin pikeys recent comments is also
kind of important for the way you
interpret this fantastic for Easter Egg
so it should go without saying that this
probably does not mean that they're
going to debut the Fantastic Four in
spider-man 3 they're not trying to tell
you oh they're coming right up next it's
more of a winged cat comic book Easter
eggs as well as future stuff and Marvel
phase 4 without any really hard dates on
anything like of course there's going to be
a new Fantastic Four movie but they
haven't told us when it's coming yet or
who the actors are going to be another
really good example of a really cool
Easter Egg like this that doesn't
necessarily mean things are happening
fried away is the venom Easter Egg yes
there is a Venom symbiote Easter Egg
that happens earlier in the movie in
Venice when he's fighting the big
hydro-man monster I'll do a separate
video about that too because it is
pretty cool and it's a nice week at the
symbiote saga in the comics but they're
not trying to use it to say that Peter
is going to be wearing the symbiote in
spider-man 3 so be careful that you
don't take a lot of Easter eggs as being
super literal or them nailing themselves
into a corner about what's coming right
up next Kevin Feige recently came out
because people were asking him and
there's a sign there is the Fantastic
Four the people that bought the Avengers
tower and he says you know we love to
watch people speculate on Marvel movies
and find these Easter eggs but
oftentimes a lot of speculation winds up
being incorrect so all he was really
saying is is that don't assume that the
Fantastic Four are the people that
bought the Avengers Tower that could
still be anybody so if you're still
holding out hope that Oscar is the
people that bought the Avengers Tower is
still possible that they could use that
because it does sound like based on the
end credits with Jay jonah Jameson
outing spider-man spider-man home run
he's going to be running from a lot of
his villains all over New York City in
spider-man 3 I really do like spider-man
Home Run is the title of spider-man 3
you could do it run home but I think
home run just plays a little bit better
when you think about the scope of a
second post-credit scene with Nick Fury
on the sword Space Station and what that
means for the future of Marvel movies it
also means that they're pushing in a
much more scientific space-based
direction and this just provides a lot
more opportunities for Fantastic Four
characters to get involved they're known
as Marvel's first family in the comics
but they're also Marvel's first
science-based family because of mr.
fantastic
they're the original science bros of
Marvel Comics because they debuted
before most of these other big
characters that we've seen in the MCU
there been a couple scenes in recent
Marvel movies that have hinted at
Fantastic Four in Norman Osborn Green
Goblin
Oscorp things remember ant-man in the
wasp there's a lot of stuff going on
with a quantum realm just a whole lot of
territory for them to explore if they do
more ant-man in the wasp films if they
don't they can just use that in other
people's films a lot Fantastic Four
because what is one of the biggest
concepts to come out of some of the more
recent Fantastic Four titles the idea of
the multiverse the idea of the negative
zone so you just have a lot of Marvel
characters traveling the multiverse if
anyone's going to do that Fantastic Four
characters would be great for that if
they don't want to double down on
ant-man in the wasp and stature now
because remember we're in 2023 so Cassie
Lange is
still a teenager old enough to take the
mantle and become a hero in training
with her father it was a really cool
deleted scene during that movie of the
actual quantum city within the quantum
realm it's implied that Janet Van Dyne
had been living there with those beings
and she had sort of been altered a lot
of theory crafters are trying to use
this as a potential path to x-men
because they talk about the way she was
fundamentally evolved like she's no
longer totally human then you have
deleted scenes like this where she talks
about the life forms down there there's
so much we didn't know about this place
Henry world of the world entire
civilizations far more than we ever
theorized so when you think about Marvel
phase four Fantastic Four multiverse
just start to think in that direction
and I still get a ton of questions about
Mysterio's story during the movie about
the multiverse was he lying about the
multiverse the good thing is is they
already established that in the Doctor
Strange movie so all the scientific
stuff that he's talking about is still
sound the only thing that he was lying
about was his actual backstory being
from another earth in the nature of the
elementals I could use someone like you
on my world
I'm sorry new world from just not there
are multiple realities Peter this is
earth dimension six one six I'm from
Earth 833 we share identical physical
constants level four symmetry
I'm sorry you're saying there's a
multiverse because I thought that was
just theoretical I mean that completely
changes how we understand the initial
singularity deceasing sorry Paul Rudd
has said that he's not totally sure that
they're going to make ant-man the wasp
three so he's like people please start a
petition so it just hasn't been
completely confirmed what they're going
to be doing with quantum realm Fantastic
Four next in the MCU
but the really good news is is that
Marvel phase fours comic-con panel is
happening in one week as I'm posting
this video some of you probably won't
see this video till a little bit later
of course I'll do videos for whatever
they reveal but let me know in the
comments what do you want them to do
with the Fantastic Four when they bring
them officially into the MCU do you want
a solo movie first where they reboot the
characters or do you want to see them
appear in somebody else's movie first
that venom Easter Egg video in the green
goblin Easter Egg
you should post in the next couple of
days there was also a really funny
Chris Hemsworth Thor parody that he just
posted so I might do a separate video
about that too but congratulations to
hit Endre patel you're the giveaway
winner from my last big Marvel video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here for that new Avengers endgame deleted scenes
video and click here for
all my other Easter eggs from the
spider-man far from home end credits
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!